you want a little uh billionaire alpha
you can go and you can actually buy
investment property what ends up
happening is that you can write off the
interest payments what rich people do is
they will actually go and they will buy
their house in all cash so they'll go
buy a you know 50 million dollar home
and they'll just be like hey i got the
cash big boy stroke check then they'll
take their house they'll use it as
collateral and they'll take out a loan
against their house but they don't use
the cash to buy the house because they
already own the house they then go use
that cash and they make investments with
it and now when they pay off the
interest even though the loan is using
their home as collateral the same way a
mortgage would it wasn't used to buy
your primary residence it's actually
used to invest and so now your
quote-unquote mortgage payments are tax
advantaged that little nuance did you
use the debt originally to buy the home
you don't get the tax advantage if you
bought it in cash and then take out the
loan against it then you use the cash
for something else now also tax
advantage